Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
OpenAI GPT-2 is a learning-based technique
which can perform common natural language
processing operations, for instance, answering
questions, completing text, reading comprehension,
summarization, and more.
What is absolutely amazing about this technique
is that it is able to perform these tasks
with as little supervision as possible.
This means that we unleash the algorithm that
they call GPT-2 to read the internet, and
it will learn our language by itself.
To perform this, of course, we need a lot
of training data, and here, the AI reads 40
gigabytes of internet text, which is 40 gigs
of non-binary plaintext data, which is a stupendously
large amount of text.
You see here an example of how it fares with
text completion, and the results were absolutely
amazing.
And, not only that, because, hold on to your
papers, we can now try it ourselves and my
results show that it can be wise as a scholar,
and it can also cheat like nobody’s business.
So, let’s try something simple here.
Well, first, as everyone is talking about
job security, I’d like to give it the start
of this Two Minute Papers script and see if
I am about to be replaced.
Let’s see!
It continues the intro with “The history
of Eastern Europe since 1989 has been an interesting
and complex story spanning four decades.
On one side you have a regime of Western-backed
dictators from the mid-1990s” and so on.
Very scholarly indeed.
However, I think I might be safe …for now.
And now, something that I wanted to try since
the inception of GPT-2, which is, feed it
a snippet of something that I said about Wavelet
Turbulence, which is one of the best papers
ever written, and have the AI finish it.
I tried to frame it as an exam question and
was not disappointed be the results.
So the text is, “There was a similar technique
by the name Wavelet Turbulence, which is”,
I hope you see what I did there…and look
what it did!
“There was a similar technique by the name
Wavelet Turbulence, which is not at all what
we are talking about, but I'll let you decide
whether it is worth your time to read it.”
Wow!
GPT-2 has been caught cheating red handed.
I love it.
Let’s continue what it had to say: “Anyway,
my aim here is to describe how we use a fluid
simulation to simulate smoke and liquid effects
using just a few simple equations: Solving
a few functions gives us a set of derivatives
of the particle trajectories, that is equations
that describe how and where the particles
will come and go across the liquid in the
simulation.
For simplicity (as a good teacher of high-school
students should know) we can use a simple
equation, which simulates two particles that
collide.”
I am stunned.
It recognized that we are talking about fluid
simulations, which is already remarkable,
but it went much further - The completion
is not bad at all and is not only coherent,
on topic, but has quite a bit of truth to
it.
I will have to rethink my previous claim about
my job security.
The even crazier thing is that the size of
this model is about 750 million parameters,
which is only half of the size of the original
full model, which is expected to be even better.
I put a link to this website in the video
description for your pleasure, make sure to
play with it, this is mad fun.
And, GPT-2 will also see so many applications
that we cannot even fathom yet.
For instance, here you can see that one can
train it on many source code files on GitHub
and it will be able to complete the code that
we write on the fly.
Now, nobody should think of this as GPT-2
writing programs for us, this is, of course,
unlikely, however, it will ease the process
for novice and experts users alike.
If you have any other novel applications in
mind, make sure to leave a comment below.
For now, bravo OpenAI, and a big thank you
for Daniel King and the Hugging Face company
for this super convenient public implementation.
Let the
experiments begin!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!